[Music]
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about whatever we
want essay and we have sherry back today
oh look at this look at this little
this little trick give me a rabbit
rabbit
grab it take your dad and he had it
you know you know that's do you remember
that song no no no
you just made it up i know you're
freestyling joe just threw me a snake
i [ __ ] with drake and he makes
matcha not cake that was really rap
i thought you're gonna say wait you
can't make sure
give me a topic [ __ ] it let's go let me
really do it let me really
shrimp shrimping ain't easy cause it's
got
a shell but i'ma still eat it because
what the hell
imma do everything i can to get cute
then i'm gonna put your girl on mute
could she be talking too
much and she'd be trying to touch but i
gotta stay six feet
skeet not today i said not today
i don't know what i'm doing this is i i
i love how i always like want to do it
and then when i do it it's just a crash
and burn situation that was great i
would freeze on the very first rhyme
dude i literally can't make a rhyme like
to save my life so i'm super impressed
not my best i'm gonna say you want to
rap she's already rapping with your [ __ ]
you do you like i dabble i dabble one of
the first things
of my career technically if you will was
uh this character called little tasty
we will y'all know a little tasty uh
kobe jersey
rapper hmm first time going viral we're
boomers
yeah i don't know um so yeah was it on
tikataka
no no it was actually on facebook we put
on facebook and it just got like
millions of views and like it just it
was just fun it was off the top
a lot of um spinning rhymes if you will
and
yeah so just being like you know a big
fan of hip-hop i've always wanted to rap
like literally in sixth grade i was
writing raps
and like you know watching 106 in park
and trying to like
be jin you know what i mean who wasn't
who's your favorite rapper
yeah you're well here's a loaded
question but like
the side of me like you know i i ride or
die for drake but that's like
a side right right or die for drake but
that's a side
that's like a facet of your honestly
kanye is like really
upsetting these days obviously but but
don't let his feelings change
no the music i do enjoy the
michael jackson's my favorite what about
r kelly
oh yeah yeah yeah our kelly's kind of
changed yeah a little bit
his feelings now are tainted
because all those songs are meant for
the sex slaves god damn it it's tainted
right step in the name of love for his
slaves
oh gross right for little girls
step in the name of love for 13 years
we'll say i'm right or died for drinking
that's cute i don't know if i want to be
his wife or his like best friend or his
like
you know they could be the same pretty
good yeah that's true
or his sister you know i can't tell i
can't tell i just love him so much in
every way
mm-hmm you know yeah sister was a
curveball
[Laughter]
it's the same thing or cousin who always
you know shows up late to the potluck
you know opera hub it's still the same
thing do you all have like a celeb that
like
you want to be like their best friend
when's the bonnie hmm i love her nice
so is uh vanessa michaels my my uh uh
roommate producer
musician person when stefanie's dog it's
her title
i don't know because we've had so many
titles like we lit a co-worker from
friends like roommates to just all of
the titles okay
um except the one title lovers never if
you become friends with gwen stefani
jill can you bring him over to do
karaoke with me
yeah you're going to want to go head
ahead with gwen stefan no we're going to
do it
oh head to head as in like duet or do it
duet both do it she's kind of hot still
oh she's hot she's definitely wait how
old is she i'm looking up i don't know
but
i'm gonna time warp myself to being 14
and i'm gonna bomb the [ __ ] out of her
oh wow was she your uh teenage crush
kind of she was my teenage person but i
used to listen to her music and it just
spoke to my heart man
oh there's something like popping jams
yeah cool i was not even in a
relationship and i'm like don't speak
them
[Music]
yeah honey i played a snake all day
no my my dreamland best friend that i
have no control over that for some
reason she's always my best friend in my
dreams is kim kardashian
i have no control over this literally i
don't even follow her
like i have nothing against her but like
i don't follow her like she just pops up
in my feed constantly and she's like
incepting my brain it's either her or
kylie jenner
do you watch the show though she's not a
fan i don't watch the show
i literally don't follow a single one
but somehow i always have dreams that
they confide in me because there
there's too much pressure of like being
so famous and i'm like
it's okay girl i'm popping up in there
in their mansions and then i'm just like
it's so weird and random
what that what's what are some problems
that they confide in um
like uh just how crazy the [ __ ] media
is and like how much it affects them and
like oh they make so many speculations
that are not even true and like
it's just all these like they're just
venting what do you tell them yeah what
do you
what do you say oh i'm just there i
don't give advice i'm just
i'm just an ear you're here right that's
so interesting
you're such a good friend in your dreams
wow and in real life
oh my gosh oh and in real life i'm sorry
that is yeah
i'm becoming skilled in that i don't
know what see i actually have a lot of
love for kim kardashian like she's
you know and i've seen interviews yeah
i've seen interviews her dave
david letterman and like it just you
know the home girl's just out here doing
her best you know and the kids are so
[ __ ] cute i
cannot get enough of the [ __ ] kids
like it makes me want
children aren't they getting a divorce
you're no no
okay
their lives are kind of going this way
but i feel like even though i don't know
him at all i feel like kim's nature
is that she won't let that happen like
she will work and fight for i like how
you're all defending her
[ __ ] moral she's a traditional [ __ ]
the beautiful kids you know what i mean
it's like
uh i don't and i think because of like
the the image aspect of it like them
them being so and they're close like
they're her and her sisters and
like they seem like they're very big on
family right right togetherness
i get you i actually used to think
courtney was like the snackiest
just for the record what's the young one
with the cosmetics one
kendall oh it's kylie kylie oh kendall's
also stunning too
she's cool is she the model one right
yeah yeah i like her too
yeah yeah they're all beautiful we can
hate as much as
they are i wasn't i want to force them
with all of them
maybe even the dad too yeah i'll take
them all
dude i had such a crush on robin he was
oh i was a little about to say when he
was dating adrian milan like literally
like he was like my
number one crush yeah but see like how
do i know so much about these people
don't even follow them oh i
watched it the media is close follow
them yeah
the media covering themselves maybe you
like follow everybody that follows them
right you know it's honestly i blame
daily mail because i'm always on daily
mail trying to find articles for the
show
and they're always reporting and like
everything about their lives so i'm
always reading the headlines
i forget which one is which i know the
names of all the kids
oh what is it ivy blue no
that's not
[Laughter]
about the name so north saint
chicago sam wow and then uh carnegie has
some p-s-a-l-m
with the silent p um courtney has uh
rain penelope and mason
i just know mason and penelope and then
uh corny has true
kylie has stormy uh rob has dream
these [ __ ] names are wild yeah
they sound like bath and body works
lotion
like candle name this army dream
yeah that's it why would you name your
kid dream
you're gonna get [ __ ] up that's a cute
one that's a nice name
out of all the names you heard that was
the one
i never did you guys gave that name to
him yeah you read you write paperclip
i wanted a name like potato or something
cute right that's way better that's like
popo
katie katie tater tot tater tot or
crispy
crispy boy you know crispy dream
stupid true was named after her grandma
see i know it's because of the [ __ ]
head oh
wait was that her name yeah is that true
what about lies
true or false true was a grandma
grandma's name
wait what the grandma's name is one of
the grandma what that whole
family's business built on lies like in
case you're not
yeah oh my goodness you know that well
speaking of production no that's the
vibe that one time
do you know this place called dream lab
you know dream lab so
i had a friend that wore their dream lab
it was just like a computer um it's like
a counter-strike
cafe so i had my
grandpa's laptop and i was watching the
kim k ray j
uh porno nice and i got a virus
no yeah i got a virus why would you
watch porn on your grandpa's lap i don't
know something was wrong with mine or
something but i was watching on my
grandpa's laptop
and uh it was a pc i didn't know what
that was going on i guess you know
um and pc sure for a paper clip
and i it was just like virus the [ __ ]
virus i freaked out so then i took it to
my home who works at dream lab
and i told him i was like oh i was
watching the kim k rage porn and i got a
virus and he didn't know what the [ __ ]
they were
it's so interesting though like the
difference of like because you know
they can't relate to what the hell we're
doing right now you know what i mean i
can relate to i just have no idea who
the names are so i'm like
since we're on the topic of porn though
it's really fun what are we not on the
topic
please ourselves and our us and our
partners and today's video is brought to
you by
adam and eve yes it always catches me
off guard
it's so good really i do great segues
huh thank you
especially when i'm talking about
people's illnesses well anyways
free stuff is awesome but free stuff to
spice up your bedroom is even better
just like
uh sherry out there with her snake
skills she knows how to
work a snake i'm like you're the same
you are she knows how to [ __ ] charm
that snake look at her go
okay select almost any one item for 50
off and then adam and eve loads on the
free stuff
enter offer code otr at checkout and get
10
tantalizing free gifts and a sexy item
for him
a special gift for her and a third item
you'll both enjoy and six free spicy
movies
plus free shipping that's otr offer code
otr at checkout
adamandeve.com get your sex
on baby get your sex on baby adam and
eve
adam and eve could be even even calm
could be adam and adam
slash otr could be adam and snake could
be adam and snake
well could be even apple
snake and apple yo speaking of apples i
used to not really like them
but these days apples are like the [ __ ]
i found a secret okay do you all put the
apples in the fridge or do you eat it
out oh
sexual a cold apple what is he doing
with the apple no i love a cold apple
i love a cold apple what i'm saying okay
you put the apple
in the [ __ ] randomly is you pull out
the apple
you slice it you can't eat it whole okay
you slice it and you cover
it and then you get the chamoy
apples peanut butter okay go away
i love peanut butter too maybe caramel i
need to feel the pain on the tongue
what happens i need to feel the pain on
the tongue not why we need to go through
the cactus with [ __ ] spikes on it
then
you know what do not ever say never
i tried it i've had cactus first of
all yeah but without the spikes though
right i hope to god
they're like tacos you know oh yeah i
look directly at you
tacos it happens just tastes like um but
yeah
i don't like that don't do that anymore
wait what geo what is your
she's a mexican too ethnic makeup um
i wear a little bit of mexican a little
bit of what would you have guessed
did you guessed last time on with tiff
oh yeah no we didn't guess
no i guess she literally guessed
everything but i don't know i went
virgin i went [ __ ]
everywhere all over the world kardashian
i don't know
i mean i went mongolian before i went uh
mexican with you but i don't know i mean
something
actually gio could could could could
it's gonna be the first time i ever hear
what's about to come out of her mouth
have like asian i knew it i've never
heard that before
wait you hear it all the time all the
time
because she looks hop up yeah cause it's
the light uh
wait there's actually a japanese porn
star that looks like her
what's her name mario ozawa oh
everyone's like
wait mario everyone watching mario mario
i think she's like spanish and japanese
they say mario dammit
yeah wait so she is
latina like half latinos during that
time because you had the same similar
haircut
so then every every time in the comments
oh my god it's mario zama mario zawa
i need to look her up she was really
famous for gang bangs like she did a lot
of big things
really so your doppelganger is like a
doppelgangbang yeah doppelgangbay
that's a t-shirt honey that's a [ __ ]
t-shirt doppelganger
game would you ever do one would you
ever do a gang bang
remix um okay game how many people are
in this game
up to you it has to be more than three
though more than three
a true gang bang it's more than three
they both are they're like [ __ ] it see i
feel like the gang bit
see that just reminds me of like someone
dipping a fry and ranch
ketchup oh i know that that's more girls
than what
no that's all the way around so i don't
know
ketchup honey mustard that's the gang
bang but that the full girl
no no no no you don't dip the fry it's
more you put the fry down and then all
the sauces at the same time oh they just
kind of
all right
there's a lady that likes to dip on
other sides right outside okay
so like what if it was a reverse gang
bang which is you and a bunch of ladies
whoa interesting that would just be like
see the word game bang is so intense
that's like a flower fest
that's a speedball hour it's a sleepover
that is
last thursday um that is a spice girls
gangbang does change it a little bit huh
yeah because game is just so why does
gangbang mean bang is such a danger we
call that
we call we would call that a finger
linger a finger linger if you will
if you will skirt i don't know isn't it
better as a linger finger
linger finger never mind i call that a
hexagon come again
this is what i would tell these ladies
yes you would see that would just be
like a female orgy it wouldn't be a gang
bang like
yeah it's octagon it's all the girls
right it's like human centipede but like
yeah i just want to know when you
watched ray j and the kardashian
card who were you watching at that time
to be honest like
i'm to be honest uh both
proper i'm a proper pure buy like a
proper box right in the middle right in
the middle
wow but is it like right in the middle
like you have a 100 appreciation for
both or you got to go 50 50.
like how does that work oh 100 100 so
two
whole pies you're given 200 ability to
appreciate it
that's amazing i think i think so that's
cool maybe that's kind of like
when i watch uh lesbian porn and i like
them both
a lot so i'm like 100 each so i'm like
yeah i'd even watch like men
gay porn well because it's you like both
so it makes sense
talk here because i don't the straight
dudes don't often watch that but like
there's something really important and
often we don't
yeah gay men i heard that straight girls
watch gay porn too
yes i've never seen a
guy and guy porn bart said he did
really he said he jacked off to it to
make sure to see if wait
no you're saying it that's the truth
no let him finish the story we want to
know what do you want to know the funny
way or do you want to know the truthful
way
both okay because they wanted to kill
the fun the truthful
protector husband right now so you go
with the money and you go with the truth
all right the funny thing is
bart was jacking it as hard as he could
to gay porn because he's trying to
figure out what
how to appreciate bart is a good old
scientist he has to make sure
so he was jacking like his life depended
on the focus group right to make sure
you know he wanted to be he wanted to
know if he was gay or not what was this
2002. oh god i got it i was in the
picture
no i wasn't and he had to just
make sure that he finished and he tried
it over and over and over and over and
over and over and over again so
he's like he popped in the dvd yep he
got the boner
and he just he got the boner the dvd
he downloaded it on google open it on
wynam
and he goes baby he goes maybe the asian
guys didn't do it for me maybe i need
some white guys you know and then he
kept trying and trying
that's my baby hey very persistent very
persistent
you got to get all the you know
experiments the hypothesis
exactly the [ __ ] hypothesis
what else is in the scientific method a
hypothesis how about this is this three
times
the hypotenuse he came for the 300th
time
he was like he was like i don't think i
am gay
you know in that case off of that though
i will ask the ladies who who you all
are i mean
you know we don't need to do labels but
you all are straight right yeah so do
you all ever watch
um well well that's the only thing i
watch
probably watch you guys don't watch guy
and guy i tried watching like
heterosexual
stuff and not so boy and girl are we you
know just not yeah
and i just i'm like i don't like looking
like
social media i'm not attached to someone
that i'm [ __ ]
i don't like looking at dicks it's not
touching someone i'm not [ __ ]
interesting so then the girl stuff
earmuffs no um so the girl stuff you
guys watch it because
because why because like because you but
you don't feel attracted to the females
um like i don't want to [ __ ] the females
i just like what they're doing and it
seems like it's the more realistic
route for me where i'm like oh i can see
that being very pleasurable whereas
when i see a guy and a girl i'm like
that [ __ ] is not funny right so that's
not realistic for you when you see a guy
and a girl oh the way that they're
[ __ ]
the way that he's [ __ ] her and like
like he'll barely be touching her and
she's like oh yeah and i'm like
right i gotta put your ass on you like
it's there's something more sensual
about like the female experience for
sure
uh chicks finger banging uh with nails
on
oh as soon as i see that i'm like oh
[ __ ] i'm changing
that's unrealistic do you like the girls
with the strap-ons
do you like the girls [ __ ] the girls
with the strap-ons i found more though
i'll go there but
so you don't need a physical penis in
your porn actually for me
even though you like penis irl well for
me for me personally i don't
ever like very rarely do i ever even
watch porn but when i do
i find myself always looking for like a
girl playing with herself with a toy
i like that solo yeah we're porn friends
when you seldom do is casey in the
picture or is this like
on your own on my own because i tried
showing him some of the stuff that i
like like the girl
playing with herself and he was like
this is weird because i don't like
looking at faces either
oh yeah you pick the ones where yeah you
don't see the interesting
there's a lot of good people on pornhub
that do exactly that
without the face and they're they're and
their bodies are
[ __ ] yeah i'm like really picky too
it really
manages them yeah so then like when i
showed him he
he was like thrown off because i guess
it's not what he liked and then that
that kind of like made me insecure like
showing no porn shaming
i totally did porn shame but i did the
same to you in the past too like
early days when we first started dating
you guys don't shame
shame shame shame it's already something
that's such like you're so vulnerable to
have to
you have to have to share it and then
for someone and like i don't even think
you guys
ever were like oh because of what it is
but i think on your personal you were
more like comfortable you were like
oh [ __ ] and i think that reaction yeah
yes it's more of a hug yeah but it's
judgment
nonetheless right well it feels like
judgment it's exactly i think it's that
i think it's because it's something so
vulnerable and intimate
even though we do share a lot of
intimacy but also
in that time when we were sharing that
kind of intimacy with each other
there was still like a lot of like room
left to share before even getting to
that point so we were
a lot more fragile about sharing our
intimacy well let's like
you don't want to come on the floor i
know i think we're at a pretty good spot
yeah
yeah yeah we just haven't been attempted
i think for me too it's like you know
porn is such a
very personal thing you don't do that
with anyone else you know it's like
it's an act that you do by yourself so
it's like share it with someone it's
like
this is so [ __ ] weird especially with
boys growing up like just being so like
you know uh
like yeah yeah alone time there's like
almost like shame around the fact that
you're
like jacking off to something and then
like but now
right yeah i don't know and i'm the
weird one because i want to share my
porn
you guys are weird
you